I asked a question, Dr. Jen's Facebook group. Dr. Jen is a practitioner in
Pennsylvania or Virginia or something over there. She just interviewed me for her breast cancer
thing that's coming out of January. So I just talked to her and interviewed her on my podcast
a couple times. I think she's interviewed me a couple times. I really like her. She was a breast
surgeon who just gave it up because she just said I'm doing more harm than good and she wanted to
help people in a different way. She just was led to help people in a natural way. She's learning
functional medicine and try to help people in that way. Asked a question on her on her Facebook
group about formal blockers to reduce tours. And if it works, even though estrogen doesn't cause
cancer, Dr. Jen said that estrogen positive cancer tumors mutated themselves by making more
estrogen receptors and therefore decreasing estrogen temporarily through, like, the rheumatase
inhibitors, may temporarily shrink bulky tumors. This made sense because I remember my colleges
even saying that sometimes the rheumatase inhibitors stop working. I then asked her if circulating
tumor cells and any cancer phone in the lymph nodes will have the same receptors as the original
tumor. She said not always, which is true. So you could have cells at the same cancer cells
at different spots that may not be ER positive, PR positive or her two positive or negative
as what they biopsy. That's not our common. And so I have tried to figure out when to stop the
horrible blockers because I do not intend to take them forever. And I think this person's oncologist
wants them to take them forever. Because I think that's kind of what's typically recommended.
My best activity is next week and I'm supposed to take another round of horrible blockers this Friday.
Can you tell me if Dr. Jen's explanation makes sense? If I am making a reasonable assumption that
any circulating tumor cells or possibly lymph node involvement, I won't know the terms of surgery
if that's true, but have any extra receptors who will be ER positive. Yeah, I don't know what the
percentage of that possibility is. I don't think anybody could tell you that. I'm thinking it's a
reasonable assumption that the blockers would possibly protect me until we could take a closer look
at why this mutation occurred in the first place. I hate the effects of the blockers. They're long
term and convinced they're horrible. And I want to do what's best. Then I'll send you a cheek swab
three days after surgery as we discuss to see if the horrible is still coming up.
I think you're just another example of you guys just be so brilliant to do in your homework and
trying to figure this out yourself. Bottom line, I know Dr. Jen mentioned that you just got to
trust your gut. I wouldn't use that terminology. I really think you just need to pray about it and
listen to the Holy Spirit and what he's telling you to do. Sometimes, you know, I mentioned you
do a person today. Sometimes God allows trials in our life. I know he never, God doesn't tempt us to
sin. But that does allow trials in our life for the purpose of molding us and shaping us more to
the image of his son. That's what sanctification is. He allows struggles in my life to mold me and
shape me to be more like Jesus. And sometimes I'm embarrassed as a result of the trials because I
don't act more like Jesus and and God has to teach me another way. But that's what his goal is
you become a believer. It's to mold you and shape you to be more like his son and sometimes trials
drive us to a deeper relationship with him so that we can get answers that we need or just trust him
in a deeper way that we've never had to trust him ever before in that way. It's easy and
American to call yourself a Christian and you never go through struggles. Never go through problems.
You think about the the Christians in other countries just this morning on the mission that
worked is listening to six people in Libya that Libya is a Muslim country, six people that have become
Christians that will soon become executed just for their face. But we don't go through any of that kind of
stuff. And you know, cancer is another type of trial that all our trials are to drive us to him
in a closer relationship to him.